can a 30 berberine supplement really
replace ozempic it's time we look at
what Nature's ozenthic can actually do
[Music]
hey everyone it's your girl Abby let's
get into it because there is a lot here
to unpack but a quick reminder to check
out my description a huge thank you to
fellow Rd and diabetes educator Aaron
Davis for assisting me on this project
if you are struggling with insulin
resistance definitely reach out her
contact is going to be below along with
the link to my ltk page for my outfit of
the day and my free Hunger crushing
combo ebook Okay berberine berberine
berberine I actually spent I think
almost like two years taking berberine
myself and I had none of the now
desirable side effects just basically a
lot of diarrhea but
okay before we go too far I
half session mud water so you need to be
a hardcore Abby Stan to know that your
girl loves her coffee the dilemma I face
is that I also have insomnia so any
heavy caffeine past noon and I'm kind of
screwed I used to honestly be like yeah
don't like matcha like so bitter so one
note but when I tried mud Waters I was
like yeah I mean this actually might be
a nice midday ritual that I can actually
enjoy it's like matcha and chai had a
baby so there's a lot more complexity
going on that I genuinely enjoy but if
you haven't heard of it mud water is a
coffee alternative with a fraction of
the caffeine in coffee and because it
contains adaptogenic mushrooms and in
the case of matcha the amino acid
l-theanine you get a slow energy release
without the big crack I've talked a lot
about the benefits of matcha on my
channel and I've also discussed the
evidence on adaptogenic mushrooms like
lion's mane chaga reishi and cordyceps
but in short research suggests that
these functional mushrooms may have
benefits for relaxation focus and immune
support just to name a few this is one
of the first mushroom-based products
that I've tried that I actually think
tastes really good because I've always
really loved the spiciness of chai and
it really does complement both the
matcha and the cocoa Blends really well
and also their plant-based coconut
creamer totally takes it to the next
level these are their low caffeine
options but they also have completely
caffeine free turmeric and rooibus for
days that I just want the ritual of like
a hot drink in the afternoon or evening
without any kind of stimulation
whatsoever so if you're trying to cut
back on caffeine or you're looking for a
relaxing low or no caffeine ritual in
your day mud water is giving my
followers 15 if you use my promo code
Abby sharp or you can go to mudwater.com
Abby sharp and you can find the direct
link in my description below so there is
so much talk right now on social media
calling out berberine as some kind of
Miracle ozempic dupe that costs about
five percent of the price with far fewer
side effects tall order right that's a
pretty tall order so
here the main use
main use for glp-1 Agonist like ozempic
and monjero are number one blood sugar
management for insulin resistance and
type 2 diabetes and number two weight
loss so let's talk about berberine's
role in blood sugar management so
berberine works like a zenpic by
naturally increasing the production and
release of the intestinal hormone called
glucagon like peptide one or glp-1 and
what in glp1's major jobs is to promote
insulin and suppress glucagon production
which helps to stabilize blood sugars
most of the data to date has shown
berberine to be effective at helping to
reduce blood glucose A1C plus blood
lipids like triglycerides so this
meta-analysis for example found that a
dose of 0.5 to 1.5 grams a day for 12
weeks was comparable to that of
traditional oral anti-diabetic drugs
like metformin and when berberine and
medications were combined the outcome
was even more significant but how does
the stock up to a powerful drug like
ozampic well first of all
we don't have any data directly
comparing berberine to ozempic but
based on the we do have so studies show
that bourbon can reduce fasting glucose
by 0.82 millimoles per liter and A1C by
0.63 for a zenpic plasma glucose
declines by
2.15 millimoles and A1C by one percent
and Metformin is around 3.1 millimoles
per liter and A1C by 1.1 percent so it's
a little over half as effective as
ozempic for blood sugar management which
is really nothing to snarl about I think
this is quite significant for a natural
health product but it's still not
comparable if you're looking for
ozempic-like results but next let's talk
about berberine and weight loss so a lot
of the studies on this to date are in
vitro or in animals but there is some
emerging human data to support its use
so in addition to producing intestinal
glp-1 vertebrate is thought to optimize
the gut microbiome for carbohydrate
metabolism and utilization while also
inhibiting the enzyme that determines
how much sugar your body absorbs the
result is that that lose weight how much
weight
a Burberry and stuff supplementation
participants lost about three percent of
their body weight so for someone who
weighs let's say 200 pounds that would
be about a six pound weight loss over
three months not bad but also that's
about a half a pound a week so not
necessarily groundbreaking either in
contrast if we look at some alglutide
products like ozempic most studies show
about a 15 weight loss and when we're
talking about its cousin munjaro that
number jumps to up to 20 to 25 percent
so this to me is like the epitome of
comparing apples to oranges like one of
these things is not like the other that
said if you want to try it let's talk
about how we take it so the typical
clinical dosage for berberine for
ozempic-like outcomes even though as
we've established it's not exactly like
a zenpic is around 1.5 to 2 grams per
day ideally spread out in three to four
daily doses a bit tedious yes but also
not a big deal the problem is that
because berberine is not regulated as a
medication like ozampic it's regulated
like a natural health product it's kind
of a wild wild west
and available formulas in terms of their
bioavailability so what we know is that
formulations that use a dispersion
method called
hcsd which combines berberine with
sodium cap rate has been shown to help
improve bioavailability and as always
you're going to want to make sure that
you're choosing a product that is third
party tested to ensure safety and
accuracy but let's assume that you're
using a high quality supplement is
berberine otherwise generally safe well
when I first posted about berberine on
Tick Tock I got a lot of comments from
folks saying that they try berberine and
they got violently ill and yeah that is
a possibility with any supplement or
medication it's not going to agree with
everyone so while the safety profile of
berberine is actually pretty good it's
not without its side effects most
notably things like diarrhea nausea
vomiting cramps and bloating anecdotally
I was on high-dose berberine to treat my
sibo which I discussed in detail in my
video right here and it definitely
worked like my my sibo is completely
clear now and then I then went down to a
maintenance dose every day which I was
on successfully with no issues for about
six months until suddenly my body just
said
oh hell no Tim I but I had like a week
of orange diarrhea because berberine is
like vibrant orange and my team and I
decided like yep time to DC that stat so
yeah it's definitely not always
tolerated well by everyone just like
ozzepic actually I also have to say that
it's really important that you speak to
your doctor before just trying it out on
a whim because you saw someone take it
on Tick Tock because it can actually
negatively interact with a bunch of
different medications another concern
that I see chatter online when it comes
to berberine is that well it might help
you lose weight it will be at the
expense of losing metabolic muscle mass
and while we definitely need a lot more
research on this it does seem that this
effect may be Administration method
dependent so one study found that
injecting berberine seemed to cause
muscle atrophy we're taking it orally
like most of us would do actually
improved It ultimately there is still a
lot that we need to learn about
berberine but what we do know is that in
the world of Natural Health Products
it's pretty powerful stuff in addition
to weight loss and blood sugar
management here is a super quick and
dirty highlight reel of some of its
potential future uses number one cancer
treatment so berberine's been shown to
have anti-cancer or tumor suppressing
potential in vitro and has been shown to
help reduce the risk of colorectal
cancer recurrence number two mood
disorders early research suggests that
berberine may have some potential for
treating mood disorders like depression
through multiple therapeutic actions
three PCOS one review found of all PCOS
treatments a combination of Metformin
with berberine was most effective at
reducing testosterone BMI and insulin
resistance in folks with PCOS and
another small study found that it
improved ovulation and menstruation
patterns for gut health so berberine
improves the diversity of beneficial gut
bacteria and has been shown to Be an
Effective antibiotic alternative
treatment for sibo which is what I used
for and five heart health bird greens
being shown to help reduce LDL
cholesterol triglycerides and
inflammatory markers so it may be a
really good adjunct treatment for heart
disease if you want me to go into more
detail on some of its other benefits and
uses let me know in the comments below
but I hope that this was a helpful
overview of the potential benefits of
berberine and whether or not it will
ever replace a powerful drug like ozampa
again a big thank you to Aaron Davis for
all of her expert support if you like
this video be sure to give it a like
subscribe to the channel and hit up my
description box for my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook and to check out
what I'm wearing today and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye